et is known for its birthdays and yours
is on Tuesday yes ma'am
therefore oh no I've not accepted this
is no longer an interview it as a jeff
goldblum birthday party i can actually
cross and wait a minute
well I didn't you don't have to put it
on but I'll put mine on you've made me
so happy really I I appreciate it hey
these are nice do you did you look at
this actually this is the best birthday
I've ever had oh my gosh thank you thank
you so much
so did you did you make these or can you
buy these like this right Harry I wish I
made it I'm not that crappy seems very
crafty I'll I use one for me are you
more there's there I'll do this I try to
avoid making the audio people suffer oh
no I like it's the you can't there's no
happier sound in the world than this I
thought you'd look good in a row thank
you yeah you can't be sad right here
when you make that yeah we have to sing
our royalty-free birthday song so I
didn't have to make one out well I think
having birthday itself is wrong for you
it is now it is now it didn't used to be
I really yeah I didn't know that you
must know all the but you sing I don't
you sing I sing up a storm not well but
I like to sing and I'd pester people
with my singing all the time but on my
new album speaking of which which comes
out November 1st I do sing and we
recorded me singing a song but we have
other good singers on Fiona Apple and
divided out of that but the world
according to Jeff Goldblum what are your
birthday plans what's one thing you want
to accomplish in your new year that's a
good question well my wonderful wife
Emily is gonna give me a birthday party
at our house I've been in the same house
for 30 years but I never I was always I
never miss an hour place of bounteous
hospitality and there we have all sorts
of events we had a pumpkin carving we
have two kids before year old a two year
old we have a bunch of kids over the
other day having a pumpkin carving thing
anyway we're gonna have a birthday party
for me I'm coming so that's what we're
gonna do for that and then my this next
year is if all goes well and I continue
to keep
sitting up and taking nourishment I'll
maybe we'll do more fees there's
certainly a little more you know getting
the word out about this which I enjoy
there's the album which comes out and
then we go and we tour with that we're
gonna play for the queen of England at
the Royal Albert Hall November 9 then we
go to New York and that and there are
many other things like that and then
yeah maybe well I'm hoping we do more of
these because I really love loved them
and then it looks like I'm gonna do that
picture that Jurassic world picture with
rice and Chris Pratt and that should be
Colin Trevorrow is the spectacular in
the writer/director I look forward to
that and there might be something after
that so I'm busy I'm busy
booked and busy is that I never heard
that oh yeah I'm busy yeah what do you
uptown I'm like I'm booked and busy like
I got a lot going on hey that's I'll use
that booked booked and I'm busy I wish I
could but I'm booked and busy yes I
always say you know my I'm my plate is
full to bursting my schedule is
chock-a-block better I like that better
actually
I like booking okay thank you so much I
love the show I wear I can't believe
right I'm so sorry so great
[Music]